I don't like pausing new positive thing
man alright let me add just like it Oh
your new boyfriend he's white he's
single white female in me I'm just
saying you know he came over to watch
the game we shared some depressing times
together some good food this is because
he's an Eagles fan I won't be an Eagles
fan laughs I wasn't done explaining our
night yeah sweet dessert treats that's
great
some high fives were involved wings
he loves wings this is the most pet I
like pet EJ it's his favorite food well
yeah pet EJ Wow you keep it on the
offense there we're not holding it ready
to say no hell yeah there's no there's
not a radio in this world that
could take this is my Danny so door I
don't that's what I was gonna say I'm
already out while you were talking on me
being scorned by my radio husband for a
man that I brought around I basically
you're not scorned I honest this is like
when when a rich guy hires when like the
wife is like we need a nanny get an au
pair cuz I didn't this Brazilian girl
comes in and then the husband's like I'm
gonna marry the au pair you're out of
here and she's like well no that's what
I am
[Music]
Shayne me both think you look really
good on a longboard dude I'm so I'm so
uncoordinated that a longboard would
result in my death I'd never put two
feet on a skateboard my life it's never
happened one time not once not one time
every duelist we do a bonfire X Games
words dude from the heart of shame if I
can get on when I would be impressed to
myself I've put always put one foot on
it yeah I roll it back and forth
sometimes I go no way really that's I've
done that a hundred times in my life I
yeah I'm like a baby deer I can't skate
at all when I see a guy run and jump
onto a skateboard and start skating I go
you might as well grass that guy could
probably do brain surgery yeah he better
probably do a standing backflip
yeah no doubt yeah some believe standing
backflip again I believe if I believed
in myself I could achieve that use like
a Kip up if I just believed I could
accomplish it yeah and saw the
follow-through in my head the same way I
tell him he arrived did Comedy Jam and
Phoenix when I I was gonna get on the
front of the bar to sing yeah and it was
like a barla definitely gonna push
myself up and put my plane at my foot
but all I saw my head going up for it I
was just like I'm gonna miss it and then
throw my knee up there last-minute
nervous and then have to roll onto a bar
it can't be a fat guy rolling onto a bar
to go sing a song that's what they kick
fat people out of bars for when we I
went and saw st. Paul in the broken
bones with Ari Shaffir and Greg hipster
brag yeah it's real hipster brag shirt
but the guy got stuck on the amp
crawling up he's like kind of a chubby
dude and like a leopard print suit and
he like he's singing and he goes oh I
just stayed where you Scott I'm actually
gonna need a little help seriously guys
like I really like my knees caught in a
funny way and I wow I was like dude this
guy's not getting down and he's just
saying it and this is his voice all of
it just you watch him after this song be
like okay alright then just slowly
back down to my first Marilyn Manson
concert ever he came out on the stilts
he has thing he comes up with stilts and
a big crutch
handles yeah and he's got a helmet on
like a weird leathery helmet with a
microphone attached to it and he's come
out to sing the song that does sound
also very like 1,800 circusy you can see
a helmet still yeah that is supposed to
look bizarre and the world's tallest man
and he usually sings the mic would just
wasn't working and watching him like try
at one point like scrit but watching
somebody scream Rock when you can't hear
a word they're saying if you just see
like it's like wide open mouths can I
ask the question of if we don't have
video of it was he walking around on the
stilts in like an evil way was he trying
to get creepy because that takes my
character so when you have a technical
failure you're like oh god damn it guys
I'm coming for you so nobody does he
ends up just going like even funnier he
gets angry he realizes it's not working
yeah and he just like he throws the
crutch handles away and watching
somebody Huff off in 3 foot high stilts
is one of the fines because he's like he
throws the thing he's yelling something
off stage and that's to go like bud like
an old Uncle Sam I bet it does blunt the
blow to watch the person that's about to
yell at you walk over and circus fashion
yeah like I'm about to get yelled at by
a guy on stilts so this this won't be as
bad if he was grounded yeah guys sorry
quickly they'll technically have to go
backstage
just to still walk everyone just enjoy
this balloon animal twister ahead go
over here and get this technical problem
sometimes evil evil doesn't work with
its microphone sometimes people the
circus brings you live entertainment
that goes already if we can just take a
quick intermission right now watch this
bear running on a ball back when the
circus meant something yeah that's right
animal we're here about elephants first
our thinking about how elephants
elephants how many people do elephants
kill you those numbers no one's talking
about those numbers he's got a it's
funny to think like you know we're like
a subject that no one's been provocative
about but you're like I'm gonna be
perfect like bring back the circus and
they're like why is this yours I miss it
cuz the circus used to do cool or
an excuse to wear a glow necklace yeah
oh man there would be so many animal
rights activists Oh like this is the
enemy we've always wanted oh yeah it's
just I do it bring back the circus
devices for hashtag bring back the
circle where's the circus everyone likes
the circus for animal cruelty I don't
know more accidents so Roman get with
these animals never take let's go Rome
in humans versus animals let's make it
count for something
bring back the circus lions fight
prisoners and Catholics specifically
Catholic prisoners we go weird odd one
thing oh man we lower them in the
fighting religion in prison and then we
feed him the Lions shout out to Marilyn
Manson for sponsoring us it's gonna be
our dark Overlord walking off do you
have a picture on those stilts just
probably a video of it going by assume
it's not the first and only time it ever
happened what that he had technical
issues although still yeah cuz still
walking is such a with it but without
the stilts doing like the creepy spider
thing yeah
are you just angrily like it's just a
clunky hook yeah you have the clunk oh
yeah because here he's like okay yeah
and I look this it looks fun yeah with
the crunch handles it looks super fun
you imagine just coming out of the
bucket stick
answer your door with it yeah I'll just
take that
just put it up holy
why are you gonna go hey hey soldiers
moving over like a giant spider I don't
like it
weights up got some here for the fantasy
football draft hey guys
table for two use of two high tops two
tickets for the hate you give we'll take
the stairs yeah oh no need just trying
to be on an escalator I'll
tighten those things you can even pick
you're watching this like he throws
those crutches away he looks like a
doofus yeah evil like evil rock and roll
goes corny real quick yeah as soon as
you get backstage and went to a brightly
lit dressing room yeah yeah and you just
sweaty and covered in makeup yeah that's
why as always I was I mean you have to
go Isaac can you get me a towel that's
where our age differences is because
like Motley Crue and like the hair rock
and like the glam metal of the 80s to me
was ridiculous because I was young
enough that it was over by the time I
was into music yeah I was like oh these
guys are just wearing makeup but they're
like he was so cool at the time and I'm
like okay just cool in like a place
because no one in my neighborhood at
that time went here's what they would do
the goofy hair for sure yeah a half top
tank top great without a doubt that's
what I think I should bring back no one
went full-blown like makeup glam metal
to shame dude yeah
look what look what the cat dragged in
killer tuned got some good tunes
those hair bands but man it was so you
know what I'm saying such as genre of
music it's always funny to me that also
like the satanic rock when you look back
at it you're like this isn't scary like
glarb maybe holds up is like well that's
pretty terrifying and weird but
when you see like Marilyn Manson like
teenagers now wouldn't be like oh that
guy's evil they'd be like Oh Marilyn
Manson being dangerous now yeah yeah
that's what I mean you don't mean that
fat neck guy who juice on sons of
anarchy yeah and you'd be right yeah but
like Ozzie Ozzie is like another one
where it's like if in the seven
like he bit heads off bats he was just
crazy and I was like good even that how
about when he went like in hair man oh
you gotta remember Oz he was famous
through hair man yeah so I mean he's a
legend so Ozzy wins what I'm saying
cause he went the hair metal at a point
no I'm say he dropped evil yeah
quick the way the kiss went disco and
when I bring up the shot in the dark
video of Ozzy it's to fight it'll make
you be like was this guy really looked
at his little yeah look that dangerous
well you know is is like as a wrestling
fan Hogan and Hogan Knows Best like
completely ruined Hulkamania because
yeah yeah you seemed yelled at it by his
wife and she's like Terry it didn't do
this right Hulkster kicked out of the
that takes that takes that away too and
I you're saying about Ozzy but seeing
them on the table its I know but it's
killed if you just have to enjoy his
music because before that watching a guy
be evil yeah being glam evil glam is one
of the gayest things ever yeah I mean
with T's Chippendales hair is this the
video we're just going through some
technical issues listen guys here at the
bonfire
we're human Eve technical issues we
start late sometimes cuz it doesn't work
sometimes our aussie videos download
properly but you can change this by go
funding my bring back the circus you
bring back the circus and dance odors
Jimmy G tour
if I leave the show Shane comes in
potato potato
I'm following that handsome son of a
bitch racking up double use next season
you're gonna be his motivator I'm gonna
in a poncho it'll all come together
oh what's wrong we can watch the video
I'm not getting an official video for
shot in the dark there's live
performances that upsets me it's a such
a ridiculous video try to find it on
something it's a never went like he
didn't change you know like I would try
to think what would be once but I'm
saying like Marilyn Manson what did he
change to he went that know that he did
all the goth yeah it was like the
goth Willy Wonka then it was the
goth Mork Nine Inch Nails leather straps
and even OH but then the next album he
went like glam rock like the dope
showing on I completely changed
really
he followed like David Bowie's
trajectory in like you know a much less
accessible way I'm not gonna lie did not
know Marilyn Manson went that deep you
don't remember the whole when he wore
that had the tits on the album that was
when I was like being introduced to him
like by the time I caught wind of
Marilyn Manson but you've seen I mean
before that it was what it was all like
yeah I fit I saw all that but I yeah I
mean he went back to the goth thing to
me that was like oh yeah that's real or
Manson that's how I learned about
Marilyn Manson yeah but that was
mechanical animals I mean you see when
he's young I mean just a goofy skinny
ugly kid was like scraggly long hair
yeah then he became a beautiful piece of
art yeah I mean that but I have to say
it like I'm just joking when I say yeah
but you'd really do I really hold on to
that you know piece of art I should did
eyes uh I should have had the
cheek a dick when I said that or just
stroke when I out of your mouth he
became beautiful pieces are the second
picture the second picture down in the
second road the second of him having a
regular conversation as I have a brick
wall in that outfit is is but he's your
buffoon or he looks like a hooker push
to the point you know what I'm not gonna
go back and sell Cutco knives for the
summer and then I'm gonna go back to
beauty school
yeah the John's liked it when I dressed
a little weird they like to call me you
know they called me mad max a lot of
people don't know is I could take out
six of my front teeth I'm like a snake I
can I'm oh the video does not exist
I'm finding it on weird sites when you
play it it says the video doesn't did
Sharon Osborne flex that
disappearing power what she liked ask
why you can't find her shot in the dark
video cuz Ozzie knows what's out there
showing before I die state put me off my
clam please take down the shot in the
dog video
I didn't know what I was doing I liked
all of his glam yeah what's his glam I
didn't know that I didn't know he went
clan I mean I mean this is the song this
is hair rock for sure you like the song
this is not my favorite Ozzie song but I
probably because the video he looks
hosted do you remember it
oh he's wearing like a Liberace Wizard
okay Bing it go to Bing Jacob I'll get a
still of just as his hairs it's just
poof his hair yeah he's going I'm
finding like a he's got Swayze
Chippendales hair oh man but looks like
an idiot can I just say the first time
like this is this is the first time I
felt like this radio show is like a
submarine because I'm like crostini just
like being at your second I'm I'm trying
everything I got I'm not getting I'm
getting nothing on this it goes the
power shallots we got a thing the whole
don't know our backup generators all
up the whole grids blown I don't
know what's going on there's a link on
vh1 classics but then the videos like
not actually there it's not a classic I
thought it was close eh wonders think
it's a classic what if I told you the
video was never filmed did you bring it
yeah I type in the word tit also oh
dude should we go to take a break and
then come back for that clip we got to
start with that clip we do let's also
seeing the break if we could find this
Ozzy Osbourne video because it's worth
putting it out there I mean he looks
ridiculous yeah I want to see it yes
that would be the video for sure why did
they have it scrubbed I always find it
interesting when scrub from the
internet Chris Rock's first pitch and
this that's what's been scrubbed and now
my favorite my favorite worst comic ever
video from from YouTube Wow yeah for the
moment right now it's my favorite but
whatever
no one cares Shane or made me feel
pretty good about it
what what did you say what I didn't say
anything dude I love you so much
let's take a break it's the bonfire
Pancho Dan's coming
[Music]
you